The Flash’s second trailer is building
the hype and we’ve got a breakdown of
the good and the bad of how the fans are reacting!
Ezra Miller's Barry Allen may or may not have
a future in James Gunn and Peter Safran's DCU
following "The Flash" star's string of arrests and
assorted controversies. Gunn's monumental praise
for "The Flash" indicates that regardless
of Miller's behind-the-scenes troubles,
the film is nothing short of
a complete and utter delight.
“I completely broke the universe”
"The Flash" is set to premiere on
June 16, and thanks to CinemaCon,
people who aren't directly affiliated with the
studio have finally gotten a peek at the movie.
If their first reactions are anything to go
by, "The Flash" is one intriguing piece of
superhero cinema. Critic and journalist Scott
Menzel tweeted this after seeing the film:
"The Flash is hands down one of the best
superhero films of all time. No joke,
The Flash is the ultimate movie going experience
as it has a little bit of everything! Action,
emotion, heart, humor and plenty of nostalgia.”
He also praised stars Miller,
Michael Keaton, and Sasha Calle,
as well as the movie's considerable
rewatch potential. Menzel also made
a point of noting that the movie has
plenty of extremely spoiler-y surprises,
which writer Nicola Austin mentioned in
her Twitter analysis, as well, sharing:
"The Flash is a compelling, character-driven flick
with a real emotional core & game changing stakes.
With heart & humour aplenty – along with
some shocks & surprises – there's so much
to be excited for. Keaton steals the show with a
terrific performance. A real love letter to DC!"
The majority of the first reactions from
CinemaCon shower "The Flash" with some
extremely high praise. Fandango’s Erik Davis
thinks “The Flash” might actually be one of the
very best superhero movies out there. He ranted
on Twitter about his love for the film, saying:
"DC's The Flash is TREMENDOUS! Forget DC, it is
without a doubt among the best superhero films
ever made. An all-timer. Inventive storytelling,
FANTASTIC action sequences, great cast. SO
MANY nerdy details. I'm in tears at the end.
Everything you want from a superhero film & more."
He also compared the movie to the
time-travel classic "Back to the
Future." Eric Goldman of Fandom also
tweeted good things about the movie,
praising "The Flash" for its
creative decisions and sense of fun.
“You’re strapped to your parachutes.”
“Where’s yours?!”
“Whooo!”
Of course, not everyone who's had a chance
to watch "The Flash" is entirely enamored
with it. However, DC fans should still
be pretty excited by the fact that even
the harsher critics are quick to admit
that the movie is fun time. Andrew J.
Salazar of Discussing Film wrote
his opinions on Twitter, saying:
"The Flash manages to deliver glorious
high thrills. Andy Muschietti captures
what many of us have always
dreamed for a cinematic Flash
story. But there's also plenty of just
*bizarre* decisions. Some story related
and others technical. Not amazing
but still pretty good at times."
It's worth noting that all this praise
comes with the movie still missing one
big piece - the hype-building post credits
scene. Eric Goldman explained on Twitter
that he expects a different closing when the
film actually goes to open in theaters. All
that said – "The Flash" packs plenty of
punch in its own right ... and the studio
might still opt to add a game-changing
stinger or two as the icing on the cake.